[Musik]
guten abend und willkommen zu einem
kurzen nachrichten überblick in der
halbzeitpause
es sei nicht würdig wie die eu-staaten
mit aus seenot geretteten migranten
umgehen
das sagt innenminister seehofer er
startet er jetzt mit seinen
eu-amtskollegen einen neuen versuch die
geretteten gerechter zu verteilen
fast 25.000 flüchtlinge haben seit
januar den riskanten weg über das
mittelmeer gewagt die meisten anfang des
jahres dann kamen weniger auch wegen
corona doch seit mai flüchten wieder
mehr menschen über das wasser richtung
geben
aus brüssel berichtet stefan leifert
über mehr als sieben stunden streckte
sich die video schalte der
eu-innenminister kein wunder dass
seehofer r mit der ratspräsidentschaft
nun die mutter aller konflikte in der eu
die migration
es ist ein sehr dickes brett das wir
hier zu bohren haben
da haben sich ja schon viele in den
letzten jahren versucht aber ich glaube
wir gerade nach der diskussion von heute
bin ich begründet zuversichtlich dass
wir hier endlich ein regelwerk in europa
hinbringen können wie dringend nötig das
ist zeigt die ocean viking vor sizilien
zwar konnten die geretteten inzwischen
von bord doch für ihre verteilung fehlt
jede grundlage für sie und die
hunderttausenden die jedes jahr nach
europa kommen doch die eu hat gerade
andere prioritäten
die kommission hat ja gerade ein großes
paket vorgestellt mit dem haushalt und
dem corona wiederaufbau fonds deswegen
warten wir mit unserem vorschlag wie
sich die eu einig ist
fünf jahre schwelt der streit nun schon
hause seehofer muss sich in der rats
präsidentschaft an diesem thema messen
lassen
der stillstand bei der migration geht
weiter daran ändert auch die deutsche
ratspräsidentschaft nichts horst
seehofer hat heute einen vorgeschmack
darauf bekommen die mühsam einigungen in
europa sind wenn es ums asylrecht geht
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat die
rechte von asylsuchenden aus afghanistan
gestärkt die karlsruher richter gaben
den beschwerden von drei betroffenen aus
berlin statt sie haben nun
anspruch auf einen rechtsschutz der ihre
mögliche abschiebung verhindert bis
grundsätzlich über ihren asylantrag
entschieden ist der korona test hat es
bestätigt brasiliens präsident bolzen
awo ist ein coup 19 erkrankt wohl so
naro sagte in brasilien
er habe sich schlecht gefühlt und
erschöpft außerdem habe er
muskelschmerzen gehabt und fieber der
präsident hatte die pandemie bisher als
kleine gruppe bezeichnet auch in
menschenmengen trägt eher selten eine
maske brasilien hat mit 1,6 millionen
infizierten nach den usa die meisten
corona fälle christophe hocke rat in rio
wird der präsident jetzt seine corona
politik ändern
jetzt fragen sich natürlich hier gerade
viele aber sieht ganz und gar nicht
danach aussah hat kurz nach bekanntgabe
des ergebnisses öffentlich gesagt dass
ich eigentlich ganz gut fühlt dass alles
halb so wild wäre am liebsten gleich
wieder spazieren gehen würde also gleich
wieder angefangen die pandemie
herunterzuspielen sozusagen die wirkung
des virus und das könnte durchaus
politisches kalkül sein weil ich denke
dass er offenbar fest davon ausgeht
selbst einen milden verlauf zu erleiden
und wenn das passieren sollte wird es
noch eher stärken bei seinen anhängern
die verehren den er schon als mythos das
ist ein spitzname erst recht nachdem er
eine messerattacke damals im wahlkampf
überlebt hatte und wenn er jetzt eben
auch noch relativ unbeschadet aus dieser
infektion herauskommt würde ihnen das
weiter stützen man darf nicht vergessen
bei aller umstrittener diskussionen hier
gibt es keine kritische mehrheit gegen
boll szenario etwa im parlament als er
sitzt trotz allem ziemlich fest im
sattel bei seiner anhänger in sehr sehr
entschlossen weiter unterstützen
christoph volkert live aus rio de
janeiro vielen dank für diese
einschätzung für australien sei es in
sachen corona gut aus doch jetzt
verschlechtern sich die zahlen deutlich
und das hat drastische folgen
aktuell gibt es etwa 200 neue
infektionen pro tag die allermeisten
davon im bundesstaat victoria und in der
mega metropole melbourne
hier gelten ab mitternacht wieder
strenge ausgangs beschränkungen für etwa
fünf millionen menschen
normen odenthal uniformierte auf den
straßen überall kontrollen die polizei
von melbourne kann das co
virus nicht stoppen aber den strikten
kurs durchsetzen den die regierung für
australiens zweitgrößte stadt verhängt
hat ab mitternacht für die nächsten
sechs wochen gilt für alle bürger eine
ausgangssperre
sie haben keine andere wahl die
alternative heißt aber tausende neue
fälle sehr viele menschen im krankenhaus
und unvermeidbare tragödien nur die
nötigsten wege sind erlaubt arbeiten
essen einkaufen arztbesuche die zweite
welle hat eine andere dimension mehr
infektionen als je zuvor und nicht aus
dem ausland importiert heißt das virus
hat sich im bundesstaat victoria
eingenistet was auch die nachbarn
alarmiert was drüben in victoria
passiert hat das in australien noch
nicht gegeben und deshalb treffen wir
für new south wales jetzt auch maßnahmen
wie nie zuvor und schließen die grenze
australien schien lange auf gutem kurs
durch die korona krise und will jetzt
alles tun um wieder in die spur zu
kommen denn das ist die bittere lektion
von melbourne
dieses virus gibt sich nicht einfach
geschlagen nach deutschland bei uns die
zahl der neuinfektionen erneut leicht
gestiegen im durchschnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage haben sich 430
menschen täglich neu angesteckt gestern
waren es noch 400 jugendliche finden
soziale berufe wie erzieher oder
pflegerin durchaus attraktiv allerdings
schrecken gehalt und mangelnde
aufstiegschancen viele ab das ist das
ergebnis einer studie die
familienministerin gipfel heute
vorstellte man müsse nun bei der
aufwertung der berufe vorankommen so die
ministerin
trotz staatlicher milliardenhilfe bleibt
die lufthansa im krisenmodus weil der
lukrative langstreckenverkehr weiter
schwächelt setzten die frankfurter den
rotstift an
bis ende 2023 soll jede fünfte
führungskraft stelle wegfallen teilte
das unternehmen mit
1000 weitere stellen werden in der
verwaltung abgebaut betriebsbedingte
kündigungen sollen aber vermieden werden
das wetter bringt sonne und regen die
details hat gleich gunther tiersch
das war es ganz schnell von uns
ausführlicher berichtet dass heute schon
mal wie gewohnt um viertel vor zehn
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen spannenden
abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
und haben wir zuschauer morgen regnet es
mal wieder in der mitte deutschlands
aber vorher müssen heute nacht eben noch
ein paar schauer nach osten abziehen im
westen tauchen neue auf die sich morgen
dann über die mitte deutschlands legen
deshalb die temperaturen dort nur 14 bis
19 grad in der nordhälfte im südwesten
28 grad da scheint auch die sonne den
ganzen tag über auch an den küsten aber
zwischendrin regnet es besonders hier im
westen in den mittelgebirgen und
vorübergehend wird auch mal ein bisschen
windiger ja der freitag bringt die
wetteränderung sturm und gewitter ziehen
nach süden und am samstag hat sich das
wetter wieder beruhigt ich wünsche ihnen
einen schönen abend und machen sie es
gut